foreign
my name is Alessandra and I am from
Colorado Springs my boyfriend and I both
have quite a bit of stuff we love things
with patterns and nice colors and in
general we gravitate towards those
Cottage Vibes a little too much to
subscribe to the minimalist look
we want to move in together in a year
and it will be a smaller space
given that how should my boyfriend and I
pick and choose what comes into our home
from each of our individual homes
so what's fascinating here is you don't
have to be a minimalist
Alessandra to live intentionally what
you're really talking about here is
intentionalism and we're not prescribing
living intentionally we're also not
prescribing minimalism no you and your
boyfriend might not be minimalist and
that's totally okay but you can simplify
your lives in several ways one way is
you talked about moving into a smaller
space I want to be clear that's not a
morally better thing to do
but it might be preferable to you and so
it has a lot to do with your own
individual preferences not having too
many preferences having really rigid
preferences is a type of prison I know
from my own experience and my own
preferences I can have a really well
decorated prison cell and so holding
those preferences loosely
but here's a really beautiful bonus
between you and your boyfriend you both
have similar tastes it sounds like I
know my wife and I are in a similar boat
here where we'll often defer to the
other person because we trust their
preferences especially if something's
more important to Bex I'll give you one
example we were just we have a home
office and we're talking I don't want I
don't like rugs I don't want rugs but
she would really like to have a rug in
the office and so I say yes to that why
because I know she's not going to pick
out some hideous now I say hideous not
as a judgmental thing but hideous as a
oh this offends my preferences right and
it would be a problem if Alessandra and
I were dating or her boyfriend and I
were dating because I don't really dig
The cottagey Vibes right it doesn't mean
I think they're wrong for having those
preferences but if Bex turned our office
into a cottage Edge I would not enjoy
spending time in there but because you
have similar preferences I would say
defer to the other person at the same
time though what's always been important
to me is to include the other person in
all of those decisions here's one rule
that we have in our home that has
prevented Myriad fights disagreements
arguments in our house and it's we don't
bring anything into our house unless
both of us agree that we want it in our
house and that means it's a conversation
before anything gets purchased and
brought home now that at first causes a
little bit more work for us and
sometimes even a little bit more
friction up front right but that
friction gives us the traction we need
to make sure that our relationship does
not completely go off the rails one last
rule that I have for you that I use in
my own life is never claim
Hold On Loosely and let go
enthusiastically if you're moving into a
new space you know Bex and I bought a
new house earlier this year we moved
into a new space and
it was never clinging to anything that
we brought in so it's like oh I have to
have this
if I have to have this ever comes up
that is a sign for me that oh I'm
clinging to this
now what is the next ingredient there
Hold On Loosely I'd like to have this I
want this in my life okay but I know I
can walk away from it I know I can live
without it I know that I'm willing to
let go and if I'm willing to let go then
I can hold it Loosely as long as it adds
value to my life as long as I feel like
it's doing something for us and it's not
getting in the way because if it gets in
the way then it's clutter and if it's
clutter and I'm still holding on to it
that's when I know I'm clinging and
finally let go enthusiastically it's not
ah I guess I have to let go of this but
I get to let go of this I get to make
room I get to experience the benefits of
living intentionally why because I'm
Letting Go I'm Letting Go I'm letting go
every day not just of the things but of
the expectations of the clinging I'm
letting go of the desire for the things
to complete me I'm letting go of
anything that is excess that way I'm not
accumulating clutter TK we should do a
parody song Hold On Loosely Loosely hold
on yeah hey
you could sing it I'll write it
we'll have Bama sing it yeah
it'll be like a little duet
I plan on quoting Frank Sinatra so you
want to go first
okay at least he's warning you oh man no
you go for it man you go for it
um you know I would say that minimalism
is a philosophy of bun of abundance and
excess is the enemy of that minimalism
is about squeezing as much as possible
the stuff that matters to you into one
life the problem with that is by the
time we form any coherent concept of the
stuff that matters to us we've been so
culturally conditioned to a philosophy
of excess that our lives are crowded out
with all of these things that we thought
would make us happy but don't make us
happy or all of these things that keep
us busy and keep us distracted and so
there's no room for the stuff that
really matters because the stuff that
really matters is about our experiences
our relationships our thoughts towards
ourselves and towards others our habits
our rituals and all those sorts of
things and it can become very difficult
to be clear with yourself about that
stuff when your life is filled with
clutter but clutter isn't defined by the
number of things that you have clutter
is defined by that which gets in the way
of the life that you truly want so as
Josh said don't worry too much about
being minimalist looking minimalist
sounding minimalist focus more on making
sure that you are living a life that
reflects what you truly want now when it
comes to moving into a new place
my wife and I just recently completed a
move and one of the things that was
helpful for us when it came to moving
old stuff into our new place was to not
let the energy of the old stuff
determine the energy of the new place
instead do it the other way around walk
around that new place and say what do I
want to do in this room how do I want to
use this space what do I imagine life to
be like here you know how do I want to
be present in this environment and what
are the things I already have that seem
to support the energy of that I I would
call everything into question it's sort
of like taking over a company you don't
just keep the same team without question
you say well here's my vision for the
company and I'm sure there are going to
be some people here that are in line
with that Vision but there may be some
people that hate that Vision so let me
be willing to let go of anything that's
not consistent with the new vision that
I have for this new place did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free